did he talk to you did he talk i was
watching uh uh i watched uh
uh
howard stern talk to chris rock and
artie at the same time
they were talking about your brother
yeah and they're having a conversation
and what i thought about i had a friend
who was like a brother i never had a
brother growing up but this guy was one
of them and i remember when i i lost
this guy i remember where i was driving
when i got the call and it was the most
painful thing and the the
the
crazy thing about when we went to his
funeral was we were all sitting
afterwards all the boys like 10 of us
were sitting at the table
and everybody's looking at our table
saying why aren't these guys laughing
and crying at the same time we were in
tears adam when i tell you we're we're
laughing so hard and crying at the same
time yeah okay right and it's almost
uncomfortable because the family's like
do you respond like i'm telling you this
is how we feel about your son we loved
your son but he
pissed us off because we don't have him
anymore we wish he was here we lost him
at 27. but yeah would he call you when
he was in pain because this friend of
mine he would always call me and i would
always call him and check on him and
he's just telling me says pat i'm
struggling with this i don't like what
are you struggling we'd have the
conversation together would he reach out
was he someone that would reach out
would you have to reach out to him no no
he would reach out but then he would
isolate too because he never wanted to
be a burden you know to people so the
isolation is is it's tough especially
with drugs and
it's tough and you don't you want to try
to like help as much as you can but it's
something that they have to go through
themselves you know so
it's it's very heartbreaking to see
someone that's you know going through
that kind of thing
and you know you just don't know what to
do you don't know it puts everybody in
this kind of thing like i wish we could
just get him you know somehow help him
out you know and that kind of thing well
this has been part of your life right so
so you've been
you've had every conversation every
question every thought everything that's
gone through it's been 25 years
97 right december 18th i want to say so
it's been 24 24 and a half years coming
on 25 years so you you you probably had
every question that people ask but i'm
listening to chris what he's saying and
chris rock he's telling howard the
solution is
stop hiring him or to fire him no he
says stop any chris's recommendation is
the way you get these guys he says
number one he says a lot of the people
who are in the industry all they want to
do is they want to heal them for a
weekend to do the shooting and go back
and do your drugs and we'll give you
everything you want but then let's put
you through therapy again to clean you
out it says rather than permanently fix
a person stop hiring him stop giving him
money stop let him go broke so he
doesn't have the money to buy this stuff
and that's the only way to clean up so
they're going back and forth and then
howard says but is it really
the producer's fault is it recess no i'm
not saying it's not the producer it was
a very interesting yeah
he called the hollywood people yeah and
enablers yeah he called them enablers
because he's such an amazing talent that
they want to capitalize on that right
and they but they want him to be clean
for the role but then
not interfere
and then already artie lang who also has
some major yeah
yeah i'm not sure if you have any
relationship with artists yeah i know
already yeah so it was a really
a very interesting conversation i
listened to that same thing it was
howard stern and obviously robin quivers
and chris rock and artie all talking
about your brother but it was beyond
just your brother right it was people
struggling and they were directing it
towards artie correct yeah and they were
directly they were trying to find a
solution of what to do with these
amazingly talented people right who are
struggling with addiction yeah so i mean
this is right in your wheels i would say
definitely you'd have to put them in
depending on how severe you know it can
be it can get to be very severe which it
got to be with chris and i think the
only solution when it gets that way
lock them in a room and and and they
don't get out for a while
like for a while once a while the final
year yeah possibly more
possibly more when it gets to be that
acute yeah
for sure you've seen the movie walk the
line you've seen the movie wow you
remember that one scene
have you seen walk the line the story of
john yeah with johnny cash okay you know
what in phoenix right there's this one
scene
where uh uh uh
june carter who is played by
witherspoon which she crushed about what
a movie that's a movie i watch with my
kids my boys to teach them a lesson but
the one scene where
he's in the bed
and the guy that was selling him this
stuff comes from the side and you see
the father-in-law come out with a
shotgun saying hey get the
hell out of here
and you're seeing the struggle of
joaquin going through the withdrawal oh
my god and i saw my body go through it
we took them to
tarzana rehabilitation center i don't
know if you're familiar with tarzana red
brilliant center it's
closer to woodland hills we took him
there was like 400 bucks a day and they
had to be there for 14 days and
afterwards he was good for two weeks
and his challenge was vicodin he
couldn't drop the viking he'd take 50
he'd take 50 yeah a day and in a day in
a day in a day yeah and they'll do
anything to get it i mean they'll break
it into somebody's house
i remember me and a friend were at
the place right across the street from
conrad's i don't know what it was called
shakies shakies or shakers whatever it's
called glendale alpha brand uh or
central so we go there and i'm sitting
with them we came after a bible study i
was trying to introduce them to a pastor
to kind of see what direction we can do
to heal this guy yeah and he says oh i
forgot my jacket i want to go get it
from my mustang yeah and i told armond i
said arnold i'm going to walk out i
don't think he's getting his jacket so i
walk out right behind him he doesn't see
me
[Music]
i walked to the back
and
he opens the trunk he still doesn't see
me because i'm hiding behind an suv i
want to know what this guy's doing
he opens it up i come right next to him
he he opens the bottle he drops he's
about to go like this i hold his arm i
take the pills i take the whole thing i
put in my pocket
i've never in my life seen a man plead
for anything the way he was pleading in
that moment
yeah i've never seen him played for it
and i'm watching him
and i'm i'm seeing the pain this guy's
going through and i'm like dude
i'm telling you i'm not you're not going
to get it from me he says pat my body
hurts i'm telling you you just give me
five i'm like i'm not giving it to you
bro yeah three o'clock in the morning
arm one comes out he's crying for two
hours yeah obviously i didn't give it to
him that night i took it i walked that
and i went and found out who was selling
it to him so i want to had a
conversation with the guy that was
selling it wasn't a conversation but we
we had a situation with that guy and a
dentist was selling these vicodins to
him because it was like a way of yeah it
was a dentist because he was making
five ten bucks a pill whatever it was
geez and there was so much connection
but okay we can get rid of the dentist
there's gonna be another doctor that's
gonna prescribe illegally we can get rid
of the guy that was selling it to him
and do whatever we want to him and
eliminate him there's going to be
another guy that's going to eventually
yeah as much as the survivor has the
pain of what else could i have done
i think eventually goes back to the
individual the individual the individual
has to be willing to go through it and
as much support and change you put
yeah
man but it has to you have to get them
off there's there's steps you have to
get them off like you know
initially you know like which is you
know tough the withdrawals and all that
kind of stuff
then there just has to be and i'm going
to say it you have to turn to god you
have to make
that part of it because i think the
human being can only go so far
in in with anything that goes with
anything when you're struggling with
anything you we can only go so far and
if we don't reach out
we
just no it's not going to work we're
meant for that
i believe you know you know it's crazy
you say that you know it's crazy you say
that we're at bible study one night in
pasadena
uh hazmats i don't know what the past
church was called i want to
hear your thoughts and he's sitting
there saying when we're talking he's
praying we're the pastor's praying over
him for 30 minutes and fully in tears
this is a tough guy this is the first
guy in wilson junior high school i got
into a fight he's the first guy that'll
punch me in the face like he's not like
a lightweight we would fight him and i
all the time and we were best of buddies
right
and he had a challenge of trying to
please his dad yeah so you know the
whole thing about pleasing he he's like
i don't think i'm ever gonna please him
and it was a list of people that he was
going through and no matter how much we
try to get him to go through that phase
always coming back and feeling guilty
like you can't please folks yeah yeah
well was was chris going through the god
uh side was he going to
church was he going through you know
we're catholic you know and i think that
he had
you know the
i think there's a thing where he would
go to church and he would he believed in
christ and he believed in that kind of
thing
so but there is there's an extra step
where he just
i it for each person i mean there's
there's there's a there's a thing you
can kind of like give it lip service and
that kind of thing like i go to church i
don't know what's going on but
to really get in to really to really
give yourself to that is a different
level there's a different level there
where you have to like really
let a lot stop of stuff go
and that means 90 percent of you know
show business and all that other stuff
you have to let a lot of stuff go you
know and and just live and just be sure
and understand that you know none of
this really matters you know there's a
there's one other dynamic there too you
know chris was like in his
early 30s right mid 30s when it happened
33 you know guys at that age oftentimes
are married right or they have a
girlfriend you never think about with
chris farley so he probably was on his
own a lot at home traveling new york to
chicago and sometimes if you have a
strong female a wife you know a
girlfriend they can be there to monitor
it and maybe you know be there and maybe
keep them from you know some of these
bad habits and whatnot but he was living
alone right when in chicago yeah and
that's another thing i would i would say
to anybody that's uh having trouble with
drugs get get find a girl that can
that's good for you not not somebody
that's going to be bad for you but
that's tricky with men anyway to find
the right woman that can really kind of
be there for you and marry her and be
faithful to her and and that'll get you
through a lot too yeah you know
definitely do you know what's crazy
about what you just said so you're
you're you're the age 33 right you know
who died at the age of 30 christ yeah
christ alexander the great john belushi
lipsy hustle the list it's a very
interesting that 33 definitely wasn't
christmas
it might have been beluxi but he wasn't
different
all these stories
what's been your experience with drugs
partying alcohol you know listen we're
irish cali i mean i have my struggles
too you know and so i go
i do uh
go to program and that kind of thing
i've i'm off of it all of it now you
know but
yeah but to me it's it's it's definitely
therapy and and and god you know and i'm
catholic and i go back to my faith and i
i try to uh try to to um
make it a part of my life not just like
something that i talk about you know i
try to make it part of my life it
doesn't always uh you know i'm i still
flawed person but i but i have to make
that part of my life or otherwise uh it
doesn't work for me
when you see i mean obviously we're
approaching this endemic phase of what's
been going on with kovid but
part of the um
fallout of everybody being trapped in
their house for the last couple years is
a lot of people are utilizing drugs and
alcohol more than ever and you know
we're seeing a lot of overdoses
yeah so
being that this is more
pervasive than ever because of the
pandemic does it get you angrier than
ever do you want to speak out more about
it is it closer to home when you hear
these stories what's your thoughts on
just everything i think in general i
think there's this uh walking away from
god i think the whole country and the
world is we're walking away and we're in
a dangerous spot you know i think that
you can't do that when when the society
goes away from god then
we're seeing it i mean we're seeing it
you know we go into materialism i mean i
think we're you know in my catholic
faith we're fallen individuals and from
the start
so we're gonna go we're gonna we're
prone to materialism wealth and greed
all that kind of stuff gluttony all kind
of stuff whatever the suddenly seven
deadly sin whatever whichever one you
have which you all have you're gonna
gravitate towards that that's just human
nature so that's what we're seeing i
think i think that's what we're seeing
we're just seeing a bunch you know when
we we don't need god well we're going to
go somewhere else if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]